("Unstoppable"
by This Is Wolff)
- [Gary] 'Sup guys?
Wednesday morning.
Heading in to the office.
Bunch of early meetings,
bunch of updates on people's
businesses so
meeting with the leaders,
creative and
account strategy leaders
of different business units.
So that should be fun.
Looking forward to that and
just some new business meetings,
client stuff, should
be a pretty busy day.
Another just kind of like...
You know, it's that
classic nondescript epsiode,
oh is this episode 200?
- [DRock] 201.
- Yesterday was 200.
I love it. I love
yesterday being 200,
just nothing crazy, right?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- We didn't even
talk about about it.
- [DRock] You didn't?
- No, you and I didn't.
Oh, was Tyler?
- [DRock] Yeah, Babin.
- That's the punchline.
Actually, that was even better.
I was about to
say classic 197 or 202
nondescript episode that
nobody will really remember
13 years from now and that's the
kind of point and that
almost even speaks episode 200.
Obviously, YouTube culture and
social media culture when people
hit 5,000 fans or 10,000 fans or
500,000 fans or a million fans
or episode 200.
You know, I've done that with
the Wine Library TV thing but
since this is
more the documentation,
this is the grind.
I mean I think it's kind of,
actually pretty fired up that we
didn't even reference
episode 200 yesterday.
That's pretty much the essence
of what were doing here, right?
Just you know grinding,
documenting over creating,
living the CEO
entrepreneur life.
Trucking along, making
things happen which is
very much on my mind.
I'm very in operations
mode right now.
Very focused on making
VaynerMedia efficient and
faster, better,
stronger, meaner,
leaner and all those things.
So...
("Forgiven" by Rowlan)
Sometimes tough to look
yourself in the mirror,
me as CEO look myself in
the mirror realizing I've
allowed the org to be a
little slower than I want it to,
things like that.
It's always interesting.
Like I said to an executive
yesterday look if you're
complaining that you're down
14-0 in the first quarter,
the game's already over.
You need to think about the
legacy behind coming back 14-0
so that's where I'm at.
("Forgiven" by Rowlan)